Чотири дні тому Юлія ще жила в страху.
Тепер вона може спокійно поснідати зі своїми дітьми
в цьому жіночому притулку під Києвом.
Я побита, вся в синцях,
у мене і тут, бачите, все синє.
Він мене вдарив.
Її чоловік, каже Юлія, завжди поводив себе нестримано та агресивно.
Але стосунки у родині погіршилися,
коли росіяни окупували південну Херсонщину, де жила родина.
Із закриттям заводів чоловік втратив роботу
і витрачав накопичені гроші на купівлю алкоголю.
Коли жінка скаржилася, що їй не вистачає коштів,
щоб прогодувати п’ятьох дітей, він бив її.
Моєму синові 15 років.
Він сказав: "Мамо, чого ти чекаєш?
Ти чекаєш, поки він тебе уб'є чи нас? "
Я отримую велику підтримку від сина.
Одного разу він бив мене на очах у сина.
Донька кричить: "Маму вбивають".
Напевно, я раніше мала задуматися, чи варто жити з ним.
Я просто не знала куди і що буду сама робити із дітьми.
Зареєстровані випадки домашнього насильства
на початку повномасштабного вторгнення Росії зменшилися.
Адже мільйони людей залишили свої домівки або просто вважали,
що повідомляти про це не на часі.
Цього року багато родин повернулися додому
або знайшли новий дім і кількість випадків зросла,
згідно з даними поліції.
На сьогоднішній день ми зустрічаємося з тим,
що цих випадків стає більше. Це пов'язано з різними факторами.
Зокрема, люди були змушені проживати там з родичами,
з якими раніше не проживали або коли був блекаут і
батьки, і діти, і інші члени родини знаходилися всі в одному приміщенні.
Відповідно, ситуація домашнього насильства
відбувалася частіше і прояви домашнього насильства
відбувалися в родинах.
Війна не поставила на паузу домашнє насильство.
За інформацією громадської організації "Ла Страда-Україна",
за 2022 рік на їхню гарячу лінію
надійшло понад 38 тисяч звернень.
Статистика за 2023 рік має бути ще більшою
- лише за пів року 19 тисяч заявок.
Багато проблем лише посилилися.
Зокрема, що стосується родин, які втратили своє житло через війну.
Так внутрішньо переміщені особи
дуже часто можуть просто не знати, куди звертатися.
На сьогоднішній день в нас немає розмежування:
це внутрішньо переміщена особа,
це людина, яка повернулась з-за кордону,
чи людина, яка знаходилась на території України.
Алгоритм абсолютно однаковий для всіх.
Тому, якщо ви є внутрішньо переміщеною особою,
ви можете і маєте право в первинну чергу
звернутися до поліції за номером 102.
Ви можете звернутись, якщо це сільська місцевість,
до старости або голови територіальної громади.
Якщо це місто - це може бути представник міської ради,
це може бути безпосередньо центр соціальних служб
для сім'ї, дітей та молоді. Так само це може бути поліція за номером 102.
Ну і додатково хотіла б наголосити про те,
що є гарячі лінії, які регулюються на рівні держави,
громадським сектором.
Це гаряча лінія громадської організації "Ла Страда-Україна",
яка функціонує за номером 116 123.
Це також урядова гаряча лінія
з попередження домашнього насильства,
яка працює за номером 15 47.
Продовжують свою роботу і правоохоронні органи.
Ірина Шурхно очолює новостворений спецпідрозділ у Генпрокуратурі.
Він присвячений розслідуванню випадків домашнього насильства.
За її словами, сплеск кількості внутрішніх справ
пов’язаний із війною.
Повернення військовополонених осіб,
цивільних осіб з полону змінює формат спілкування в сім'ї.
Це і дуже важке матеріальне становище
вимушених переселенців, а також безробіття -
усе це є чинником підвищення
випадків домашнього насильства, які вчиняються в сім'ї.
Військовослужбовці чи цивільні особи можуть страждати від депресій,
ПТСР та інших емоційних і психологічних травм.
І у разі неотримання ними вчасної психологічної допомоги
це може значно погіршити ситуацію із домашнім насильством в Україні.
В комплексі так, воно підвищує ризики.
Але чи воно підвищує ризики тільки щодо домашнього насильства - необов'язково.
Тому що воно може підвищити ризики до вживання психоактивних речовин або алкоголізації.
Тобто в який напрямок це підвищення піде.
Перебуваючи у притулку, Юлія зрозуміла:
війна зробила її чоловіка ще більш жорстоким, ніж раніше.
Якби Росія не вторглася, нічого б цього не сталося.
Ми жили б собі і все було добре, і робота була б.
Для жінок, які намагаються допомогти Юлії стати на ноги,
війна не має значення. Їхня увага зосереджена на ній.
Багато викликів полягає в тому, що цих жінок
потрібно змусити навчитися себе  любити.
Їх потрібно навчити любити себе такою, як вона є,
приймати себе такою, як вона є.
Багато жінок себе не люблять.
І навіть через це вони стикаються з такими відносинами.
А поки Юлія займається пошуком роботи.
Жінка каже, що вирішила більше ніколи
не залежати від кривдника, щоб годувати своїх дітей.